Let's go.
Before you actually get started and start the modules
and start picking niches and start going through everything
and go, go, go, go, and I know you're anxious,
I know you're excited, that's why we came here.
That's why we are here.
I want you to figure out a couple of things, okay?
And I need you to figure out what is the destination?
Where do you wanna go, okay?
So when I say where do you wanna go,
I mean how much money do you wanna make, okay?
How much money do you wanna make within 12 months?
Where do you wanna be by December 31st of this year?
Where do you wanna be 12 months from now?
Whatever that goal is, I wanna know where do you wanna be,
AKA how much money do you wanna make, by what date?
That's the first thing, okay?
And you need to get really clear
on how much money you wanna make.
You need to know the destination.
So let's just say you're sitting in the Midwest, okay?
Maybe you're in Arkansas, maybe you're in Iowa,
I don't know, whatever is classified as Midwest.
And you wanna go to LA, okay?
If you wanna go to LA, there's a lot of ways to go to LA.
You could fly up to Portland and go down, you could fly.
I mean, you could fly, first of all, you could drive,
you could scooter, you could walk.
There's a lot of different methods to get there,
but there's also a lot of different ways.
There's a lot of different routes.
You could go down, go to Phoenix, right?
There's a lot of ways, right?
But guess what?
There's one way that's the fastest.
And so what I need you to do is, first of all,
we gotta know the destination.
We gotta know what you're aiming for,
because if you don't know you wanna go to LA,
you're gonna wander, okay?
So I need you to know how much money do I wanna make
and by what date?
And it needs to be by a specific date.
So we need to figure out what that is,
and then we need to have a plan
for how we're gonna get there.
Meaning, okay, if I wanna get to $10,000 in six months,
how many deals am I gonna need to do at what price per,
like how much am I gonna need to charge the client
at what profit margin?
How am I gonna get to $10,000?
Is it $10,000 profit?
Is it $10,000 gross?
I need you guys to figure out
and get clear about what you want, okay?
And so if you haven't already,
I need you to go watch the video titled Exhausted,
but Satisfied, and we will definitely,
it will be linked somewhere around this video.
I need you to watch this video,
and I need you to set your destination,
put a time on when you wanna get there,
and then I need you to create a plan,
AKA a map, for how you're gonna get there.
And I want you to be so clear
that if I were to come and scare you in the middle of night
and shake you and say, hey, hey,
what do you need to do today
to get to your goal by Christmas,
or to get to your goal that you set
on December 31st, New Year's Eve?
What do you need to do today?
And I want you to be able to go, oh my gosh,
I need to set up this many campaigns,
and I need to talk to this many business owners,
and I need to close out this percentage,
and I need to do this.
I want you to know so clearly
that I can wake you up in a dead sleep,
and you know exactly what you need to do.
Because guys, the problem with most people
is that they spend a crazy amount of time,
majority of their time on activities
that do not get them closer to their goals, okay?
And they do not move the needle.
And so before we get going,
I need you guys to set the destination,
put a timeframe on that,
and create a map of how we're gonna get there.